um you were uh talking in a few videos
in the past month on your YouTube
channel if you guys haven't subscribed
to George Gammon do so uh he has two
channels George gaming and another one
called The Rebel capitalist he also runs
a live event so definitely check him out
if you don't know about him but you were
talking about the psychotic plans of
these Global Elites can you can you dive
into that a little bit more and why
that's such a huge risk to us and the
economy right now yeah I mean we were
talking about a lot of their psychotic
plans earlier but uh from a standpoint
of macro the gal at the U.N her name is
uh Rebecca Greenspan I'm not saying I
know that last name is correct because I
remember it was the same as Alan Green's
man what is there a position there she
is uh the head of the economic depart I
can't remember exactly what her title is
but she's the one that uh kind of
goes out and tells the media what their
economic policies or prescriptions are
oh so she's providing the sound bites to
Media Outlets then yeah and she's the
one that gets interviewed and all those
things got it and so her her counterpart
over at the IMF is a gal called uh
Christina it's like giorgiova or
something like that and uh you can tell
that these two gals that are probably
the most powerful over in Europe and
Christine Lagarde at the IMF or at uh
she was at the IMF now she's uh the head
of the ECB
and Janet Yellen they're all kind of uh
uh I think they all get the same script
so when you hear what they're all saying
if they're saying the same thing I think
it kind of gives you an edge to know
what they will be pushing within the
next year and then you can assess the
probabilities of it coming to fruition
and then you can see if the mainstream
media really starts picking up on this
and if the Federal Reserve starts
picking up the on this as well as an
example back in 2019 when I first
started my YouTube channel I was talking
about a central bank digital currency
and Rich everybody was telling me that I
was a conspiracy theorist oh George
you're a fair marketing you're Alex
Jones you're a tinfoil Hatter blah blah
blah blah well now and I'm sure this
isn't a surprise to any of your your
viewers that now the Federal Reserve has
come right out and not only are they
talking about a central bank
they're testing one that's right they've
got a pilot program right now a 12-week
program as we speak or the they're
testing a central bank digital currency
how are they testing it can you can you
dive into that because I haven't got the
details and can you explain why that's
such a big risk to us
yeah let me get there in one moment okay
uh but but one of the the key crazy
things that they're scripting now which
we may see come out in the future what
what Janet Yellen and Rebecca and
Christina and Christine Lagarde what
they're talking about is capping
interest rates with the central banks
so I I think that the Central Bank in
Canada correct me if I'm wrong has been
increasing interest rates along with the
ECB and everyone knows that the Federal
Reserve is doing this and their position
is hey if you continue to do this you're
going to create unemployment or further
unemployment you're going to increase
the unemployment rate and that's not
fair to the poor and middle class blah
blah blah blah so what we need to do is
we need to increase interest rates just
to a point where it starts to negatively
impact the unemployment rate and then
what we need to do if we still have
inflation is we need to send out stemi
checks for people to afford the higher
prices for gas food shelter Etc now for
those of your viewers who are rather
sophisticated they'll say well that's
complete Insanity because that's only
going to exacerbate the problem of
consumer price inflation but they've got
a solution there quote unquote I think
what they're going to come out with and
what they've talked about is price
controls so they're going to say okay
fed you can only take rates up to let's
say five percent and once we see the
employ unemployment rate Notch up from
3.7 let's say to 4.2 now go all of a
sudden we've got to drop rates back down
to let's say four percent to make sure
that we're not damaging the poor and
middle class and then if inflation is
still at let's say five six seven eight
percent then we need to start sending
out stemi checks again and then we need
to cap inflation
because we know that that's produced
exclusively by just greedy capitalists
we know that's the reason for inflation
so let's just stick it to the greedy
capitalists that are trying to stick it
to the average Joe and Jane and will
Implement price controls so I I just
want to mention that because I think
that your community should kind of just
take a mental note there and start
trying to notice this narrative uh being
talked about more and more and more
throughout the mainstream media because
if they do that they'll be able to
understand what the probabilities are
that this comes to fruition and if it
does you'll definitely need to
understand that to position your
portfolio uh in a way that's going to
make sure that you're you're not only
you know surviving the storm uh but
hopefully you're thriving through all
these insane policies now going back to
the central bank digital currency
question uh this is really interesting
most people understand that if there is
a central bank digital currency that
means they're going to be able to
monitor every single transaction you do
it you meaning every business every
person in the entire population the
entire Society so this is orwellian on
steroids I mean this is a dystopian
nightmare to say the least but that's
not where it ends what most people don't
understand is a central bank digital
currency means that your dollars or your
Canadian dollars whatever you have in
your checking account which is currently
a liability of your local bank let's say
down here in the United States it's
Wells Fargo or Bank of America that
would become a liability of the Federal
Reserve
in other words your checking account
would move from Bank of America over to
the Federal Reserve just like JP Morgan
has an account with the FED we call it
we call it Bank Reserves a reserve
account or Goldman Sachs something like
that so why does this matter
because there's a big key distinction
between the Federal Reserve and your
local bank your local bank doesn't have
an infinite balance sheet they actually
are a for-profit business so they have
to worry about a p l right if they they
can go bust they can be insolvent now
the Federal Reserve doesn't have that
problem uh they have an infinite balance
sheet they can have negative equity it
doesn't matter they're not going to go
out of business so what this means if
everyone has an account with the FED it
means that they can start issuing credit
based on narrative
not based on Merit
see right now if you go out and apply
for a loan for a house let's say a
million bucks well they're going to look
at your credit score they're basically
going to look at your ability to pay the
loan back but I think in the future
especially if we move to this Central
Bank digital currency and they start to
ban cash they're going to say well I
mean we need to do what what's the word
Trudeau would use well we need to employ
Equity or inclusion or uh you know Fair
social credit score is where you're
going yeah we we need to have a social
credit score on what we need to do they
won't say it
it well but basically we need to extend
credit to those disadvantaged groups
right uh you know so whether it's uh
African-Americans or they're already
starting to do that right now with Banks
from what I've seen where banks are
offering discounted rates or lower rates
to people in certain groups that you
know uh
you know sort of go with the woke
narrative if you know what I mean I
think they're going to do it to a
greater degree in the future especially
if they get the Central Bank digital
currency because they don't have to
worry about being paid back you know in
fact just the other day I did a video
that the Bank of Canada or the is it the
Royal Bank of Canada your Central Bank
up there just hosted a conference on
basically being woke and this in the
Federal Reserve down here tweeted about
it saying oh yeah isn't this awesome
that the bank of of Canada is doing this
whole conference to try to figure out
how central banks can be more woke and
be and have more inclusion and diversity
and Equity so if you combine that woke
narrative with a central bank digital
currency what that means is if you're a
straight white guy
uh then you might get that mortgage but
it's going to be at 10 percent
if you're a trans Native American
uh a furry or whatever it is sure you
know then your interest rate is going to
be at one percent and uh this is what
one of the many many reasons that I
think a central bank digital currency is
so dangerous above and beyond just the
the 1984 Big Brother element of it you
know what's been interesting about all
this over the last few years especially
in Canada is the Trudeau government
slowly been disarming Canadians I don't
know if you know about this but they've
banned handguns and they're also talking
about uh Banning semi-automatic long
guns so we have three categories of guns
here we have restricted which is really
only for security and licensed you know
police forces
um we have non-restricted and prohibited
right you know prohibitor like the full
automatic uh M16s that you know the
military would use you know for example
but they're licensed to carry it but
they're talking about taking away long
gun that are even semi-automatic which
is the next step so
I'm not sure really what the
you know what the country's going to
look like in five to ten years time but
it's not going in a very nice Direction
yeah a very free Direction
and cbdc's have been talked about a lot
over here
um they're dangerous they're dangerous
because they can program the money they
can program you know where you can spend
it how long the money's uh on your
balance sheet for you know forcing you
to spend it within a week or two and not
only that rich now they're coming out
with these credit cards and these are
being pushed by the world economic
forums that that show your carbon
footprint monthly yeah so I think where
they're going with this is to your point
that programmable money they'll give you
a set allocation of carbon credits
throughout the month so let's say that
it's the the 25th of the month there's
five days left and you've eaten too many
steaks or you've filled up your truck
too many times or your McLaren yeah it
only gets six miles to the gallon or
whatever well now you can't you you
literally cannot buy any more gas you
can't buy any more steak you can might
sell it to you but at a tax rate that's
much higher right or yeah or you'd have
to pay like triple the price or
something like that uh and and how would
they do that because that money is
programmable and they can make it do
anything they want based on their
algorithm or your spending habits
there's really no way to circumvent this
either right because they're forcing you
to use a cash that's why I always say
that it doesn't seem like a big deal
Banning cash like oh who cares no one
ever uses it
goes through that's the only thing that
stands between our freedom and liberty
and the central planners and
authoritarians but it like I mean the
way they're going the vast majority of
the population who all you know is drunk
on the wokeness and wants to protect the
environment and save the baby seals and
make sure the icebergs aren't melting
they're probably going to line up to go
and get these like carbon credit credit
cards oh yeah so they convert your
signal on social media I guarantee
within the next year you'll see circles
on [ __ ] Facebook with I got my carbon
credit credit card I'm saving the
environment you know here's my number
over here
um there's going to be a lot of people
that will rush to that I believe anyway
I don't know what do you think they're
the useful idiots I I couldn't agree
more I could not agree more and I think
what will make it even more impactful is
not only this virtue signaling element
that you're referring to but also I
think this is how they're going to
distribute Universal basic income
yeah but they'll say they'll say in
order to get the the Ubi you know the
thousand bucks a month you've got to go
to your phone and you've got to download
the the FED app right and that fed app
automatically gives you that account at
the Fed so they're creating Bank
Reserves putting them in your account
and letting you spend them as legal
tender but those bank but those uh you
know uh tokens that you're getting Bank
Reserves let's just say that they're
called fed coin right that is the
programmable money and they're just
going to use that to weed out all of the
existing money and replace it so 100 of
it is programmable while at the same
time Banning cash and then then you're
screwed and then you're done I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're newer to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out